on c-span 2. from freedom fest 2009 held
in las vegas
a debate on the federal reserve
participating in the debate are
economist warren coates
wall street journal columnist john fund
barron's economics editor gene epstein
and meltdown author thomas woods it's an
hour
i'm joe bradley for those of you who
just joined us
we have a number of exciting panels
scheduled you've already heard
one in a
previous life i recently retired from
publishing investors hotline and in that
role i had the opportunity
to interview many of the top free market
analysts financial
experts economists that you you're
hearing here at this conference
i want to congratulate mark skousen for
pulling together this freedom fest it
certainly is the world's largest
gathering of
people that are really interested in
liberty that's ever been created i
understand they're around fifteen
hundred people here now
and when ron paul's group gets here
later this afternoon it's
it's gonna swell between two to three
thousand
so
on investors hotline it was always a
quest for truths
the economic truths that that run our
capitalistic economy as well as from a
practical standpoint how it's going to
impact all of us as investors
so one of the one of the overriding
themes here at this conference
as you've heard virtually everybody is
unanimous in agreeing
that the primary catalyst to the
meltdown in 2008
as well as the ongoing problems that
we're experiencing
is due to the government is various
entities
so one of the primary
government entities of course that has
been blamed
is the federal reserve system now the
purpose of this
debate this afternoon is to determine
is the fed so broken that it should be
totally abolished
or can it be modified or fine-tuned
whatever and still continue
so on my left here
to vote for defe defending the fed in
some way
we have john fund first of all
john is an american political journalist
and
columnist for the wall street journal
he's the senior editor and columnist for
the american spectator
and he's author of stealing elections
how voter fraud threatens our democracy
and next to john is warren coates
warren coats is an advisor to a number
of central banks
he retired from the international
monetary fund in 2003
he led missions to over 20 different
countries
he's a visiting economist for the
federal reserve
and the world bank he's currently
director of the cayman islands
monetary authority and he's also been an
advisor to the central banks of iraq
as well as imf consultant to the central
banks of afghanistan
kenya and zimbabwe
zimbabwe obviously they weren't
listening to you warren
they are now
and then
for abolishing the fed our next panelist
gene epstein is barron's economic editor
he was also former chief economist for
the new york stock exchange
he writes a regular column in barons and
he writes it from the perspective of the
philosophical view of austrian economics
the school of ludwig von mises
and then
and finally we have tom woods tom woods
is senior fellow at the ludwig von mises
institute
he holds a bachelor's degree in history
from harvard
as well as a phd degree from columbia
university
and he's author of nine different books
the primary book that is very
appropriate
to this discussion is meltdown
a free market look at why the stock
market collapsed
the economy tanked and the government
bailouts will make things worse
so i'll have each of our panelists start
out with a two to five minute opening
statement and then
we'll let the fireworks begin and
hopefully we'll come
up with some practical suggestions on
what we should do
going forward both governmentally in our
economy but also
for us as investors so tom why don't you
lead it off
can we get some liquidity up here in
terms of water
thank you thank you and this will
probably go right up to five and i
promise i won't go beyond that
okay a lot of people seem to believe
that although the market economy is a
swell system it requires the equivalent
of a soviet commissar to be in charge of
money and interest rates this belief is
altogether misplaced
the federal reserve system or simply the
fed is both harmful
and unnecessary since the fed's creation
in 1913 the dollar has lost at least 95
percent of its value
if the much maligned gold standard had
produced such a result we'd never hear
the end of it
but in our system the fed is for
whatever reason curiously exempt from
criticism
under the fed therefore people have lost
an option they once had
namely accumulating savings in cash
under a commodity standard people could
save for the future simply by
accumulating precious metal coins
which back when they functioned as money
held or even increased their value
no one has that option any longer in
other words only a fool would try to
save by piling up dollar bills
instead everyone is forced to become a
speculator and to invest in securities
markets they know little about
and that can wipe them out entirely if
times turn bad
as early as the 18th century richard
cantione identified distribution effects
as another way inflation harms the
general public
the newly created money is injected at
particular points
whoever receives it first in other words
people who happen to be politically well
connected
get to spend it before prices have
commensurately risen
and they thereby enjoy a windfall by the
time it trickles down to the general
public
those people have been paying the higher
prices to which the new money gives rise
all that time private and public debt
have exploded under this system
especially since the collapse of bretton
woods in 1971.
no one has a right to be surprised when
indebtedness skyrockets under a system
in which
credit can be created out of thin air
the very existence of the fed
a central bank institutionalizes the
problem of moral hazard
moral hazard involves an actor's
willingness to behave with an
artificially elevated level of risk
because he believes any any losses he
may incur will be born by someone else
since there is no physical limitation on
paper money creation
market actors know the paper money
producer can bail them out if things go
terribly wrong
they have been vindicated in this belief
time and again they will therefore be
more reckless in their investment
activity and speculation
than would otherwise be the case we were
once told that boom bust business cycles
were a thing of the past because thanks
to the fed we now had scientific
management of the money supply
if anyone believes that today i'd like
to meet him
artificially low interest rates courtesy
of the fed do not in fact yield us a
utopia of sunshine and kittens
to the contrary artificially they
artificially stimulate
capital goods production and long-term
investment
they thereby deform the structure of
production into a configuration
that the public's freely expressed
pattern of saving and consumption will
not be able to sustain
when this phony boom inevitably
collapses it is capitalism that is
stupidly blamed
it when in fact the fed a non-market
institution
is the culprit i am interested in
neither the saccharine promises nor the
technical details of the alleged
superiority of a monopoly fiat money
system
the fed is the lifeblood of the empire
the great enabler of the perversion of
the original american republic
into the world's largest and most
powerful government
even if the fed did confer a net
economic benefit
a contention the great austrian
economist fa hayek and ludwig von mises
strenuously denied
in fact hayek won the nobel prize in the
process of denying it even if the fed
did confer a net economic benefit
the alleged benefit could not possibly
be worth the destruction of the american
soul
as it turns out we don't have to make
that choice when it comes to the fed
justice economic prosperity and the
values of the original american republic
are joined together the fed
its academic apologists and the drones
in our supposedly free press who
demonize all dissent from the monetary
status quo
have done our economy enough damage for
the sake of american freedom and
prosperity it is long past
time that in the spirit of andrew
jackson we killed the monster
thank you
all right john john you want to go next
no it's important you want to go to
export okay warren
thank you very much it's a pleasure to
be here again
i want to note that my first trip to
zimbabwe was
just a month ago after the collapse of
their currency
and our uh strongest advice to them
they've dollarized
and are literally using the us dollar
was to continue that regime and not to
reintroduce their own currency
anytime soon so i would have to defend
the fed today
having endorsed zimbabwe's embrace of
the
the u.s dollar our topic is
fed up with the fed should we abolish
this is not a topic about whether the
fed should adopt a different policy
regime
such as a gold standard but whether we
should have a central bank at all i
i can't resist noting gene and i debated
the topic of the gold standard last year
at which time
the price of gold was 970 dollars
per ounce this morning it was 912. i
just thought you would like that
market update so the the first half of
the topic
fed up with the fed calls for a review
of fed policy has it been
uh good has it been bad
what's what's the score card
and i don't want to go back to the
entire history of the central bank
central banks generally don't have a
very good
uh history and and track record and the
fed certainly has
uh its its black marks over its history
as well
but let's look at where the world has
come in the last several decades because
a lot has been
learned and monetary policy has been
dramatically better
around the world including here here in
the united states
so let's start with paul volcker's fed
that killed the inflation of the late
1970s when the
inflation rate in the u.s got up to 14
percent or so
since that time it's averaged about or
since two years after that
as he brought the money supply back
under control
inflation has averaged about three
percent
per annum for that uh several decade
period
real gdp has averaged about
3.2 percent which is its average for the
last several hundred years in the united
states
up through the first quarter of this
year
and over the
this decade through 2006
leaving out the recession that we are
now in
it averaged uh three percent
per annum over this period we had about
half the number of recessions this
last 30-year period we've had about half
the number of recessions that we did
throughout our our previous history
the fed's record in these last several
decades is not
all roses
however as you know the fed
did keep interest rates too low for too
long between 2002
through 2004 contributing to the housing
price bubble
this is true but low interest rates
had other market for uh forces
contributing to the low interest rates
as well
an overvalued u.s dollar produced large
and growing trade deficits that suck
dollars in from china
and other countries keeping interest
rates
low with the gold standard interest
rates would have been even lower
until the trade deficit was
reduced as all adjustments would have
been made
would had to have been made through
domestic prices
markets are the best way
of reconciling
conflicting forces and moving the
economy forward
but but because it's the best system
doesn't mean
it's without its challenges and
difficulties and
hardships
how has the fed performed in the last
two years
the fed responded to the financial
crisis emanating
from the collapse of the real estate
bubble in several ways
first on the monetary policy front it
reduced interest rates in the face of a
collapse of aggregate demand
to soften the impact of the fallen
housing
and other asset prices and prevented a
collapse
in the money supply after september
2008 september of this last year by
doubling
base money these traditional central
bank
functions helped restore confidence in
the financial sector and moderate
moderate the inevitable recession
as the economy deleverages and adjusts
to new realities in this area the fed
has performed very well
uh not repeating the mistakes that it
made during the
great depression that contributed to the
great depression being what it was
on the credit policy front
the flow of credit froze up as financial
markets
began to realize the extent of potential
real estate losses and started to
deleverage
the fed introduced new facilities to
help specific credit markets
buying mortgage-backed securities and
commercial paper
to name two this is not a traditional
central bank function
the fed should have had greater faith in
the markets ability to develop
new credit channels and to redirect
credit
to the most productive uses in this area
fed performance was helpful in the short
run but harmful in the long run
it was inappropriate and the fed should
unwind these activities as soon as
possible
on the failing institution resolution
front
the fed joined the treasury in
ill-advised
damaging and for the fed inappropriate
and possibly illegal market
interventions to save investment banks
and an
insurance company this was motivated
by the lack of legal tools with which to
resolve failing non-banks
in the ways banks may be resolved but it
was an end run
around the law at a time of panic
it is also hard not to wonder whether
personal treasury relationships and past
and potentially future employment on
wall street
clouded the judgment of treasury and to
a lesser extent fed officials
one way or the other the rules of the
game have been
changed and are now unclear
the long run damage will be difficult to
repair
so should we get rid of the fed
the answer i'll i'll provide mine and
you can then come back with
with yours the answer
depends on whether we believe not having
a central bank would be better
in in time alternative arrangements
could be developed to clear and subtle
payments across different banks
or different institutions of payment and
to print and coordinate the value in the
market of
uh private currencies am i can you rap
can you wrap it up yeah
okay
okay the benefit would be
clear the benefit of a purely
private monetary system would be clear
rules with very strong market discipline
and private behavior
these are important benefits the costs
would be periodic financial panics and
crises that would very likely overturn
the system with massive government
intervention
let's not uh throw out the
the workable for an imaginary
utopian uh best solution
and i will leave that to
my partner to elaborate
all right gene you want to give your
point of view from the abolish the fed
standpoint
well it's fun to be appearing up in
opposition to john fund we both
work for rupert murdoch he acquired
barons and he acquired the wall street
journal
indicates to you that maybe murdoch's
world is a mention of many rooms
although the killer anecdote i'd like to
hand people is that murdock's
publishing arm also puts out howard
zinn's left-wing
people's history of the united states
the man
puts profits before politics and indeed
the fundamental reason why i am
pro-capitalist
is because free speech freedom of the
press is something i hold dear
and private ownership of the means of
production is a necessary
condition to the maintenance of free
press and free speech
similarly similarly the abolition
of the federal reserve is necessary
in order to bring back government
accountability
to the people it's fairly simple what
has happened
over the last few centuries even before
the federal reserve
was created the kings wanted to fight
their wars
they couldn't borrow enough they
couldn't tax enough
so they started to print money that's
why the government government began to
control
and get interested in controlling the
money supply in the
uh in the more recent period under
bismarck
under uh fdr it became apparent
that the welfare warfare state cannot be
answerable to the people
it's got to depend on the mechanism of
printing money
and the federal reserve is central to
that the only way to get back to
our republic the only way for the
government to be answerable to the
people
not to propose programs before it knows
how to fund those programs
is that we abolish any means by which
the government can control the money
supply
now notice i haven't said anything about
economics yet
i'm talking about fundamental political
values
that are vital to the maintenance of
freedom
that's the fundamental reason why we
have to abolish the federal reserve and
indeed
not just abolish the federal reserve but
understand
that any government control of the money
supply because
control of the money supply by the
government has been ubiquitous for
centuries
it was very very apparent in the 19th
century
before the federal reserve was created
that's also why we had
monetary instability and corruption or
indeed the war of 1812
was financed uh through the through the
printing of money
uh by the new england banks and then the
protection of those new england banks
by the government all of that sorry
history it depends on
government control of the money supply
now
why else would i abolish the federal
reserve because it causes
business cycles warren just spoke warren
coats
on the opposition just spoke about what
the fed did and didn't do
right after the collapse of the economy
over the last couple of years well let
me give you a little anecdote that does
not even require an understanding
of austrian business cycle theory the
the the the fourth
the driving force of the real estate
bubble was something known as adjustable
rate mortgages arms they were
disproportionately
where where the mortgages were coming
from where where the bad
debt was being created now adjustable
rate mortgages
are directly tied to the one-year rate
and the one-year rate is directly
dependent on the federal
funds interest rate set by the federal
reserve the federal reserve
was directly in that sense financing
the housing bubble and indeed on top of
everything else
the crowning irony is that alan
greenspan himself
got in got up in front of a bunch of
realtors and said arms are wonderful
adjustable rate mortgages are a great
deal you ought to sell them more
aggressively
to your customers that's one simple
anecdote that i suggest
warren coats embrace understand in order
to appreciate the fact the federal
reserve was part of the problem
it created the bubble and then
afterwards it runs them it's the drug
pusher
and afterwards it gets to run the
methadone clinic and claim
that it didn't push the drugs in the
first place so simply put
in order to have political freedom in
order to have
economic stability we need not just to
abolish the federal reserve
we need to declare that money and
interest rates are the province of the
free market
when uh when when congressman ron paul
asked ben bernanke do you ever get the
interest rate wrong
ben bernanke said yeah yeah you know we
do occasionally get it wrong
we try but we get it wrong and uh and
ron paul said
to bernanke well then why not
occasionally
why not eternally leave the interest
rate setting
to the market because you get it wrong
maybe the market will get it right a
little bit more often than you
okay do here's our letter
all right and now uh lastly uh we'll
have john
fund give his uh view from a
attack i mean a pro fed standpoint and
then i'll
get the ball rolling on the debate with
a question
to all of you so john
i'm not going to wear the pro hat to
paraphrase
shakespeare's mark antony i come neither
to parry the fed nor to praise it
i come to be realistic
and what we have is clearly a deeply
flawed institution
but i would remind you that
while certainly i think the fed can be
said to have exacerbated some of the
business cycles
and perhaps prolong the period by which
we flush out malinvestment
there were panics and there was market
instability that led to the creation of
the fed
the famous panic of 1907 being an
example the one that j p morgan had to
step in and sit and
ameliorate at the last minute the fed
exists for a reason
uh providing short-term financing during
periods of financial panic
i would remind you the 30-day commercial
paper market dried up completely last
fall
there was a panic there was a sense not
just in the government but among the
business community
that something had to be done to inject
liquidity into the market
promptly the uncertainty the fed causes
is a real cost
on the other hand my worthy opponents
have spent
10 minutes bashing the fed without
giving you any sense
that there is an agreement on their side
as to what should replace it
and of course yes the market they say
should replace it but
exactly what structure what mechanisms
how do we get from there
to here and i'll return to that theme
the fed has taken on far more than a
central bank
even should take on it has taken on
responsibilities regarding full
employment
uh protecting depositors through an
insurance system many other things
as richard ron points out the fed has
taken on so many responsibilities it's
become like a large fire department that
has a fixed percentage of its employees
or arsonists
so as it gets bigger there are always
more fires well i propose there is
another course we have a fed that is
targeted
simplified streamed down and focused on
its mission which is preserving the
integrity
of our monetary value new zealand had
the same problems in many respects in
the 1980s
they had a financial meltdown they
didn't become a banana republic they
became a kiwi republic because even
kiwis were in short supply in new
zealand
what did they do in response they
created a completely independent
hermetically sealed off central bank
they appointed a board of governors that
were tasked with one
job only and that was to keep the rate
of inflation within certain targets
and the head of the central bank was
rewarded
financially if he met those targets and
he was penalized if he failed to meet
those targets
a simple simple mission
a simple set of clear rules and a simple
set of incentives to
put those in place and new zealand has
prospered ever since
now i'm not saying this is easy but
neither is slaying the monster
without an idea of what you're going to
replace it with
now ronald reagan who was a follower of
the austrian school of economics
had some interesting debates when he was
in the white house with his private
advisors about the fed
and he always would end these
discussions with
well show me how to get from here to
there and we can talk about it
until then i think we should recognize
that while the fed creates uncertainty
having a debate about abolishing the fed
without having a clear idea of what's
going to replace it creates further
uncertainty
and i would submit to you at least from
the point of view of the business
community
and from entrepreneurs during that
period of time
of turbulence in which we debate the
role of the fed without a clear idea of
where we're going
we're not going to have economic growth
we're going to have perhaps more
instability
so i submit to my worthy opponents i
share some of your critique i share
perhaps some of your
values but i also understand that we
live in a practical world
in conclusion i always liked the unicorn
when i was growing up
unicorn is a wonderful creature to
behold i'm pro unicorn
but i've yet to find one and i don't
believe in spending all of my time
searching for the unicorn thinking that
i will find it
because so far i haven't the same thing
with a world in which we have abolished
the fed without a clear idea of what to
replace it
is a search for the unicorn which we
have yet to find on this earth thank you
thank you john you mentioned
president reagan and
one of the most interesting interviews
that i had
was with president reagan and at that
time i remember
the discussion we had one of the things
that we were talking about
was the tremendous power that
the trilateral commission and the
council for foreign relations have
in influencing what goes on in
government
and even at that time they had an
espoused view of creating a global
currency
and what they called new world order
ironically after the g20 meeting
the financial times herald that the
discussions were so wonderful because
headlines they created a new world order
so my question is
what do you all think practically is
going to happen
jim sinclair says that china already
wants
a super sovereign reserve currency to
replace the dollar
and it's supposed to be a critical part
of central bank's reserves
do you all think that that's the
direction we're going and if not
what do you think is going to happen i
will simply say
that the fed could use some competition
and if it comes from the chinese
communists of all people that may not be
the worst thing in the world
uh by the way i think that we are on the
verge of having a finally a real debate
about the fed because it has been one of
the most secretive and
least transparent organizations ron
paul's bill
to audit the fed now has a majority of
members of congress in the house behind
it
and
as much as much as i don't want the
chinese running a separate reserve
currency
the threat of the chinese setting up
such a thing may actually force members
of congress to ask more probing
questions as congressman paul has been
want to do
and question its role because if the fed
through its incompetence and through his
bungling
manages to lose the status of the
dollar being the major reserve currency
in the world uh there should be some
accountability and even
even obtuse members of congress may
demand that
but yes go ahead respond if this were
1985
and we were discussing the future of the
soviet union can you move the mic closer
no
it's not this goes on
oh sorry if this were 1985 and we were
discussing
the future of the soviet union i would
hope that john fund or others might say
you know ronald reagan has suggested
that maybe the soviet union should come
to an end
uh no what will happen well nobody would
have suggested
that it was going to just collapse it
was going to implode
john fund if someone were to ask him
well what are we going to replace
uh those systems with how are we going
to replace what are we going to do with
collectivized agriculture
i believe in unicorns but after all what
what is the market going to do
well the nature of the market is a
certain amount of entrepreneurial
discovery
however there is an enormous body of
literature
on the free market in banking he just
mentioned ron paul ron paul has written
about this
about competitive banking it's not
rocket science there's a great deal of
insight
about what the free market in banking
will do so
the question about where are we going
well the more
we try to understand the spirit of
ronald reagan who thought
the solution is for the soviet union to
unravel
for the berlin wall to come down the
more we will appreciate the idea
that maybe the solution is to abolish
the fed and then
understand a little bit more about the
nature of free market
so we can appreciate how a free market
in banking will work
about which there is a vast and very
well informed literature
i i can't as someone who covered ronald
reagan throughout his presidency i must
remind you
that the soviet union collapsed the
surprise of everyone almost in this room
it could have happened in an entirely
different way with many casualties
and many much destruction so while
ronald reagan wanted the soviet union
to disappear he also recognized that it
had to be done
in such a way that there could be the
least possible
casualties quite right and fed and i
think it's incumbent upon you
not just to say the market will provide
but to provide us with a road map
a gps system by which you will trace how
we can get from here to there with the
least
possible damage you have not done so you
have not carried the burden of proof
and therefore your position fails it is
not enough to say abolish the fed you
have to say how and you have to say
with such ability that you will not
inc increase market in insecurity and
you will not create economic conditions
in the short term that will make it even
harder for us to return to economic
growth
tom i think part of wait is this working
jeans mike how about this one still no
well all right gene
some kind of racket with the microphones
going on here i'm sure there's a natural
explanation
um
i think um the reason we probably didn't
get into a blueprint is that i mean
as it is i could barely get five minutes
in but i've actually got
right on my blog right now tomwoods.com
there's a blog entry called how to
return to gold
and it links to the most important free
market economists who have looked at
this subject
so murray rothbard's book the mystery of
banking which is out in a very nice
second edition in 2008
explains exactly what he would do now
his plan involves
in part requiring the fed to disgorge
its gold holdings
and then distribute those gold holdings
to the commercial banks in proportion to
the
dollars that they have and then redefine
the dollars value such that it would
they could
absorb the gold and vice versa there are
there have been
shall we say adjustments to that uh
since but
so that's that's rothbard henry haslet
who wrote economics in one lesson from
which many of us learned economics
i linked to him as well i think probably
the best
person to go to though is a spanish
economist i think one of the best
economists in the world
who has a treatise that if people read
it would revolutionize the world
and it's called money bank credit and
economic cycles and the author is
is jesus huerta de soto and it is a
brilliant treatise and the last chapter
is nearly a hundred pages in which he
explains how a free
free market system in banking with no
government special privileges no special
sugar daddy
but where banking operates according to
the same rules
as the shellfish industry or anything
else and gets no special privileges how
exactly that would
that would work i understand that
before you go to another question go
ahead code warren
um i certainly uh support greater
accountability and transparency of the
fed and can you hold the mic a little
closer
and therefore probably ron paul's
legislation i haven't read it but from
what i hear of it i would support it
your question was about a world currency
gold was the last world currency that we
had it had many virtues worked
well for quite a long period of time but
was overly rigid
and as a result of that ultimately
collapsed any
uh enduring system uh
and and the goal of a world currency i
think is
is worthy uh needs to be
pragmatic uh if it's going to survive
what the governor of the people's bank
of china
uh was proposing and referring to was
the special drawing right the sdr of the
international monetary fund
and i think that's back into the debate
and uh
deserves some serious consideration as
not as a replacement but as a competitor
uh with the dollar and with the euro
which are the two
primary reserve currencies in the in the
world today
well wasn't that dishonesty though that
the that we went off the gold standard
that's just a political decision
i suppose i'm the one who's supposed to
answer that i think i think it was
dishonest to abrogate the gold clause
and that uh and and thereby null and
void contracts that people had entered
into
that's a different proposition from
going off the gold standard as
the bases or as the peg to which the
dollar is
is fixed and that's a
a long complicated topic that you're not
going to give me the time for
it from what i understand and correct me
if i'm wrong i
it isn't it being proposed that just the
opposite of
of the fed having less powers
that the the government is proposing
that the fed will have the authority to
bypass congress
and bail out virtually any entity
that deems to pose a systemic risk
i understand that there are like 500
banks
that are on the list that are allegedly
too big
to fail somebody want to comment on that
well the basic theme involved there is
starts with perhaps reading a brief
essay that alan greenspan wrote when he
was 40 years old
uh when he was a randian called golden
economic freedom
the world went off the gold standard
because the rise of statism the rise of
the
welfare warfare state and uh the
economist
economists
unfortunately were behind that uh the uh
green the trajectory of greenspan's
career is is uh is really the whole
story
he caught potomac fever at the age of 48
and eb himself became a status it's
great fun
running the federal reserve uh the uh
the federal reserve gives the economist
a seat at the tables of power
they know they just don't have to be
just economists and journalists they can
actually
call the shots it's very heavy heady
it's very invigorating
but but beyond that what is happening
right now
politically the obama administration
obamanomics is basically stealing the
country from the american people
and it's doing it to the printing of
money deficits don't
matter of course that's what dick cheney
said and dick cheney was a part of that
same problem
deficits don't matter we can print the
money
we don't have to ask the people to uh to
pay for it in taxes
we can simply print it impose it on them
arrogate the resources to ourselves
and then we don't have to worry that's
the nature
of why this is all about politics and
indeed
alan greenspan wrote about that very
very succinctly in gold and economic
freedom
gene and i agree on many of the things
that may happen the next couple of years
which would mean
vastly increased inflation uh by
traditional standards and of course the
devaluation of the dollar and other
financial problems
that will trigger i hope a robust debate
about the mistakes that got us here and
how to get out of them uh part of that
debate should include
what my worthy opponents are proposing
but we also need another proposal
we need a proposal for people who are
not going to buy the whole that package
and we need a proposal for a slimmed
down streamlined fed along the new
zealand model
and other countries by the way have
adopted it since then
and i'm not saying it's politically easy
but it's certainly more politically easy
than what they're proposing
and it has worked tom okay
but if if we want to talk here about uh
what's right
what's wrong what's the best outcome we
can aim at
then it seems to me that this solution
whereby we should have just a nicer fed
that isn't going to do as
crazy things i mean this is like should
i have a door with a lock on it
or should i have a door that has a piece
of paper that says this door is locked
i mean wha why would i why would i
support that and and but beyond that
um it seems to me there is no moral or
economic reason
to have this money monopoly system and i
think people who favor a system like
this
that as i showed in my remarks actually
does harm people
and i actually believe causes far far
worse financial problems than than any
other system
i think we need to it shouldn't be
people who favor a free market who have
to be on the defensive it should be
people who
support this monopoly system now fa
hayek who won the nobel prize in 1974 in
the late seventies began to argue that
there is no reason if you want to be a
non-utopian
to believe to expect governments to give
you good money
especially governments with the
ambitions of the united states you have
no reason
other than mere superstition to believe
this and he says historically
it is a mere accident that governments
have been in charge of of the money
monopoly and why do you think that is
because
because they're they're just looking out
for the common good they just want to
give us a good medium of exchange we can
use for our transactions
of course not because they want to be
close to the source of the production of
money
if it seems to me if we believe in the
free market then all this rube goldberg
nonsense about special drawing rights is
utterly superfluous
what is to prevent the free market from
producing money
the same way it produces any other good
money is a good
what's the problem here warren
there is no problem with market provided
money and most of the money that any of
us use
is privately produced in the in the
private sector
what the government has a monopoly on
and
and what a monopoly is needed
for or at least highly helpful is
the unit of account all of the private
monies your
your visa credit card and debit card and
and uh
mobile phone payments which are very
popular in kenya and other african
countries all kinds of ways of paying
things
not just the old-fashioned check which
is also privately produced by
by banks all
have their value denominated in a
monopoly unit of account the u.s
dollar we cannot easily give that up
you mentioned too big to fail and a list
of 500 banks that's a fiction there
there is no list of banks that are too
big to fail and it's certainly nothing
like five
500 but i i think giving the fed
i very much agree with with john's
points giving the fed
added powers to to to deal
with systemically important too big to
fail institutions would be a very big
mistake
uh we we certainly need more
transparency and information about
what non-bank financial institutions are
actually
doing the aig
debacle was a big surprise to everyone
but i favor as john does stripping the
fed
of its supervisory powers sharply
narrowing
its focus on monetary policy preserving
the the value and integrity of that unit
of account
and again virtually all money is
privately produced so let's not
raise uh fictions
let me pose uh let me just speak to
warren's point about the unit of account
look
look brian a brief economics lesson the
market
prefers a single unit of account they're
very very powerful market forces
that produce it in fact uh the its
government
with its many currencies the yen the
shekel the
uh the dollar the knucklebuck all of
those various
competing units of account are bad for
the economic system and indeed
world traders only use one unit of
account because those are market forces
they tend to use whatever's at hand they
tend to use the dollar so indeed
i only suggest to you that you go on on
my colleague's reading list and try to
understand
that the single unit of account is the
one thing that happens
when a gold standard happens everybody
wants gold
uh the world wants gold there would be a
single unit of account
globally one one tiny tiny i promised
two sentence point
also i think it's misleading to say that
you know the money is all privately
produced this is like a great private
system
yes with a gigantic monopoly privilege
of legal tender
so of course obviously people are going
to accept this the type of system we
have now of fiat paper money being that
that is convertible into nothing has
never in history emerged spontaneously
as the result of people rationally
observing the good consequences it has
to the contrary
it has always been imposed by violence
and through monopoly force
and through the police prohibiting
alternatives so why don't we let
people instead of using sd you know
other things let them use gold and
silver and take the
the privileges off of the dollar i'd
like to pose a uh
a quickie there's no prohibition on on
goal
gold or silver anyone can
own it you can transact in it to your
heart's content but the market
has revealed its preference not
to make gold the center of the system
i'm not trying to say something against
gold and just talk
i'm just talking about the the market's
revealed preference which is for the us
dollar not for gold
i'd like to post all on a level playing
field for a change
and people could make voluntary choices
and they could actually make contracts
and they could and they could require
payment in something other than the
dollar that's the problem
the reason we can't have genuine
competing currencies is that everyone's
required by law
that they've gotta they've got to accept
the crummy greenback
not true that's not true
well i i have to add in that one of the
other things that president reagan said
to me was that he believed that
that individuals should make their own
contracts in gold if they want to
protect themselves
and he he acknowledged that there was no
country that ever survived when they uh
dropped the metallic backing although he
he
stopped short of saying that we needed
to go back on a gold standard and people
make such contracts today
right but it's got to be look guys the
simple confusion is it's got to be
too kind you and i can contract in
onions if we want to
we can contract in apples but there are
legal tender laws
that require if there's a contract
that's going to hold up in the courts
it's got to be paid in legal tender
therefore only if two parties of the
contract agreed to it
can it survive that's why it's not a
level playing field the legal tender
laws it's a simple enough point
and the taxes on gold and silver too
yeah that's right all right
we're running out of time i'd like to
pose one very practical question we've
been talking about
theory but what has happened is
that the entire global financial system
has melted down
and virtually every asset has been
plundered
and as a result we've had a
deflation in terms of if you would
define it as far as falling prices
and over the years of course there's
been a debate
even prior to this meltdown that that
we might reach the point where the
federal reserve would be
pushing on a string so that no matter
how how much credit they wanted to
create in the economy it just didn't
happen
so obviously to this point that's what
we're experiencing
now the question is bert doman points
out and the number of
deflationists say that okay so uh we're
let's say hypothetically the
the feds expanded up to 11 12 trillion
whatever just a trillion here or there
and and but but
conversely there's been 50 trillion that
has just
vaporized globally that's just gone to
money heaven
and so he thinks that in spite of the
inflation
in terms of monetary expansion that the
fed's going to do
that we're not going to get out of this
and that the dollar
is not going to go into hyperinflation
so i guess what i'm really asking is a
timing issue but
that's affects all of us as as investors
and so i was wondering if you all would
comment do you think that deflation is
going to continue
for a period a long period of time and
then convert to hyperinflation or what
where we stand in this cycle well i
think i think
one fundamental confusion uh that should
be cleared up
is that the basic process uh that we're
talking about
is a process whereby the government
finances operations
not uh through taxes not through
legitimate borrowing
which would be very limited by the way
if it ultimately had to be paid for
by taxes but through the printing of
money that's what's happening now
now the secondary effects of the
printing of money are what the question
addresses
uh but the fundamental problem is is
that that power
is slipping from our hands even more
than ever because
of the ability of the government to
finance these huge deficits and the huge
deficits by the way that eldercare is
going to
are going to charge us for the printing
of money the secondary effects are
somewhat debatable
i personally believe that price
inflation uh
which is what the mainstream normally
confuses with inflation
is not going to occur in the next two
three years
uh because we have such slack resources
we have such a
high unemployment rate it's it's almost
never occurred
that you've had that you could have that
kind of acceleration of inflation with
those kinds of slack resources so very
possibly
we will not have severe severe price
inflation we will
however have the other fundamental
insidious evil
of government deficits looming
government deficits
financed increasingly through the
printing of money as the obama
administration decides
to spend money on whatever it wants to
and aggregate
human resources in whatever way it wants
to
yes warren i'm sure gene is a better
forecaster than i am so i won't uh
i'm gonna make a different comment
than your question a big confusion that
we've heard
up here is that the fed determines
interest rates completely false
the market determines the interest rates
the interest rates we see
are market determined the fed uses
the federal funds rate overnight in
interest rates as
a mechanism for doing what it does do
which is control the money supply
that's the way it gauges how much money
it's going to put into the system
so don't think that the fed determines
interest rates nor that they determined
interest rates
even during the criticized period of
2004 markets determined those interest
rates
there was a global glut of savings in
the world much of it flooded into the
united states
and kept interest rates very low tom all
right
on the the global savings glad i'll
leave to gene but um
but in terms of the market setting
interest rates well we're not saying
that the fed
goes to a local bank and says you should
charge x percent on this loan i mean
we're not making a trivial
claim like that we're we're instead
saying that when when the fed
increases the money supply through the
banking system the banks now have more
to lend
and so something's got to give here if
they're going to lend it they're either
going to have to lower their lending
standards
or they're going to have to lower the
interest rate at which it's offered so
indirectly the fed doesn't it does
determine interest rates
that's the key point that it does it
through the expansion of the money
supply but that's also the reason why i
offered to warn the simple anecdote of
what truly happened
uh over the last several years uh as the
bubble was happening
the federal reserve set the the
overnight interest rate at one percent
that's impossible for a market to ever
believe in because it was beneath the
rate of inflation
that would not be a market determined
interest rate that interest rate
was moving the the one year rate and the
one year rate was setting
the very very low uh adjustable rate
mortgage rate so in that sense
sometimes it does it does control
interest rates at the short end of the
yield curve but more importantly as my
colleague pointed out
it basically affects interest rates all
along the yield cut because of its
ability to expand
the money supply because those those
loanable funds weigh on the interest
rate
all right to sum up i would simply say
my colleague steve moore at the wall
street journal reports that his source
of the treasury department says
they're printing money 24 7. literally
24 hours a day they're printing money so
some where we're going to see that show
up in the economy
that will give you an opportunity to
have a great debate about the fed's role
and its mistakes you should have two
plans when that debate
happens plan a is what you may really
want and plan b
is what you can get and i and it's
prudent and rational for all of you
to want your plan a if you wish it but
to also have a plan b in your hip pocket
and we've tried to provide both for you
today uh well
the the timer has been flashing indicate
indicating that our time is up so i'd
like to uh
thank our panel very much for
participating and i think it's been a
very
informative and lively debate thank you
very much
warren coats served with the
international monetary fund for 26 years
before retiring in 2003
he's currently director of the cayman
islands monetary authority
and an advisor to the central bank of
iraq
john fund was a member of the wall
street journal's editorial board
from 1995 to 2001 and writes a weekly
column for opinion journal
gene epstein has been the economics
editor and a columnist for barron since
1993
he's the author of econo spinning how to
read between the lines when the media
manipulates the numbers
thomas woods is the author of nine books
including the church in the market
and the politically incorrect guide to
american history
this event was part of freedom fest 2009
held in las vegas